-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for watching.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Former president Trump
is in the news.
Apparently he's been trashing
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
behind his back, calling him
a dull guy who has no chance of
beating him in a potential
2024 matchup.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "I have to
insult him behind his back
'cause I can't tweet it
to his face."
[ Laughter ]
I feel like Trump is slipping.
A few years ago, he would have
had like 10 nicknames
for this guy by now.
It's like, "Ron Dull-Santis."
[ Laughter ]
I think the insults backfired
'cause just hearing Trump's name
jump-started Biden's approval
rating back up in the 50s.
[ Laughter ]
It's in the 50s now. Yeah.
I think this is
actually a nice change
'cause usually when two Florida
guys get into a fight,
they're drunk and shirtless.
[ Laughter ]
But DeSantis doesn't seem fazed.
He said that he's going to
handle the insult
just like COVID
and completely ignore it.
[ Laughter ]
And speaking of
the former president,
this weekend he held
his first rally of the year.
Let's take a listen
to what he had to say.
-The grocery shelves,
the department-store shelves,
they're empty.
You had an excuse
not to buy Christmas gifts.
You say to your loved one,
"Darling, I'm sorry.
I love you very much,
but I just can't.
There's no merchandise
in Tiffany.
I wanted to buy you
the most beautiful ring,
but they don't have any rings
anymore.
Nobody has anything.
We never even heard the term
"supply change."
[ Laughter ]
-Supply change.
Well, a year off,
and he's still got it.
I think he's still got it.
I think...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think he's still got it.
He's right. He's right.
He's right.
We've never heard the term
"supply change."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then he started talking
about things
being expensive
'cause of inflammation.
[ Laughter ]
Trump knows exactly what
concerns working families --
the ring inventory at Tiffany's.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, as if we're not
dealing with enough right now,
doctors are warning people
against a new TikTok trend
called "sleepy chicken,"
where people cook chicken
in NyQuil.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-No.
-Yeah.
-What?
-There's actually another name
for chicken
that makes you sleepy.
It's called turkey.
[ Laughter ]
Just eat turkey.
That's right.
Doctors are warning people
against cooking chicken
in cold medicine.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, the recipe is wild.
Take a look at this recipe.
It says add oil to pan
then add chicken.
Then sauté in bottle of NyQuil.
[ Laughter ]
After that,
cook chicken through,
transfer to plate,
and then enjoy.
After that, wake up facedown
in plate four hours later.
[ Laughter ]
Next, stumble into garage,
drive car straight through
garage door.
Then drive to Taco Bell
on wrong side of road
going three miles per hour.
After that, remove shirt, demand
eggplant parm and a Twinkie.
Then get arrested.
[ Laughter ]
Next, use one phone call on
the only number you remember --
the house you grew up
in as a kid.
[ Laughter ]
Then spend night in jail,
join gang for protection.
After that, get neck tattoo of
prison nickname --
"Sizzurp Chicken."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then gain freedom but lose job
as high school principal.
And finally,
refrigerate leftovers.
So, I mean,
it's a tricky recipe.
Just stay away from it.
[ Applause ]
Hey, did you guys see this?
A Norwegian cruise ship
canceled its trip
mid-voyage due to COVID.
[ Laughter ]
And now a bunch of passengers
are stuck at sea.
Norwegian told the passengers,
"There's no reason to panic.
There's plenty of NyQuil chicken
for everyone."
[ Laughter ]
Passengers are furious.
They're like,
"When I booked this cruise
during a COVID surge,
who knew this could happen?"
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's just stranded
and angry.
That's got to be
a lot of pressure
for the cruise-ship comic.
"So, where are you folks
being held from?"
[ Laughter ]
I saw that over the weekend
on the Saturday edition
of the "Today" show,
one meteorologist had a cough
coming on, and she did her best
to fight through it.
Just watch this.
-Well, our friends out west have
lucked out with dry conditions
and mild conditions out towards
the Rockies.
And, of course, we're seeing...
that winter storm
that's going to impact
the East Coast.
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at your...forecast.
[ Laughter ]
-Somara getting
a little bit of water,
and she will be back with more
in just a bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, poor thing.
[ Laughter ]
-She sounds like the captain of
a Norwegian cruise.
[ Laughter ]
At first it looked like she was
just overcome with the emotion
at the sight of a cold front.
And then "I -- I promised myself
I wouldn't do this."
[ Laughter ]
Could we just watch that again
just 'cause it's funny?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, we're seeing...
that winter storm
that's going to impact
the East Coast.
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at your...forecast.
[ Laughter ]
-Some business news --
I saw that once again
Netflix increased its monthly
subscription prices.
[ Audience booing ]
Apparently Netflix's plan is
to take so much of our money
that we'll have to enter
a real-life squid game.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix says that you can
either pay the increase
or enjoy not knowing
what anyone's talking about
for the next 70 years.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I heard that
there's a new push here
in New York City to put
trash containers on the streets
so that there aren't
giant mountains
of trash bags on the sidewalks.
It's like a developer came
in and said, "I got it --
rat condominiums."
[ Laughter ]
It should be great.
This way, instead of having to
look at ugly piles of trash,
we'll get to see all
these beautiful dumpsters.
Well, guys, as the country
continues to deal
with the pandemic,
the director of the CDC
just said that she's aiming
to improve the agency's
COVID messaging.
Yeah, then
in her next interview,
she said the CDC is not aiming
to improve their messaging.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in the CDC's defense,
it's hard to get any message out
when every ad on TV
is for Caesars Sportsbook.
Yep, the CDC wants
to communicate more clearly,
so going forward,
their press releases
will no longer be
in the Wingdings font.
Some more news.
I read that Neil Gorsuch
is the only
Supreme Court justice
who won't wear a mask
to help protect his colleague,
Sonia Sotomayor,
who has diabetes.
[ Audience boos ]
You know Gorsuch is the guy
who touches every bagel
before picking one.
You know that? He's like...
You guys remember Neil Gorsuch.
He used to work
for the law firm
Rogan, Hogan & Facebook.
Hey, I saw a news anchor
in Mexico who looked like
he finally hit
his breaking point
with people
who won't get vaccinated.
Check this out.
-iUstedes! [Bleep]
[ Shouting Spanish ]
[Bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Yo!
You know that's how Dr. Fauci
feels on the inside.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard that today
former New York City mayor
Bill de Blasio announced
that he is not running
for Governor of New York.
He then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
He then waited over ten minutes
for someone to say, "Aw."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, de Blasio
won't run for governor.
He said he wants
to spend more time at home
being booed by his family.
Did he really
have to announce that?
I mean, he might as well
have announced that he won't be
performing at the Super Bowl
Halftime Show.
It's like, "Yeah, we know."
Some business news here.
Apparently airlines
are dealing with
the ongoing pilot shortage
by raising pay
and lowering the requirements.
[ Laughter ]
Passengers said, "That's nice."
And, "Wait. What?"
[ Laughter ]
This probably explains
why my last pilot
was wearing a Petsmart uniform.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's not very reassuring
when your pilot is the same guy
who drove your Uber
to the airport.
He's like, "Alright. Let's go.
Here we go. Come on."
[ Laughter ]
Now instead of needing
years of experience, pilots just
have to complete a CAPTCHA
that proves that they're human.
Yeah, they'll hire anyone
right now.
Here's the newest United pilot
I saw.
-[ Shouting Spanish ]
[ Applause ]
-That's a bit much.
-Geez.
-Well, speaking of flying,
a man went viral on TikTok
when he shared his experience
as the only passenger
on an eight-hour
international flight.
Somehow we have a pilot
and passenger shortage.
I don't know.
Of course, they wouldn't let him
board until his zone was called.
"Group two."
"Sorry, sir.
You're group four.
Group two. One more time."
It's weird
when the pilot's like,
"Uh, we will now be making
our approach, Tom."
Hey, this is also going viral.
Someone posted a video
of a FedEx driver
who didn't exactly deliver
their package with care.
Watch this.
-Woman in audience:
Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
His boss called him and said,
"Just a little more practice,
and you can do it without
slowing down the truck."
Respect for that aim,
though, huh?
-Yeah, that was good aim, man.
-Finally, a woman in Canada
was driving on a frozen river
when the ice broke
and her car started to sink.
And instead of panicking,
she took a selfie.
Take a look.
Don't worry. When the river
saw that it was a yellow Subaru,
it spit the car right back up.
This afternoon, President Biden
held a press conference to
mark his first year in office.
And this was smart.
To make Biden look good,
they had the CDC Director
go out first and open for him.
[ Laughter ]
"Boo, yeah! okay."
The press conference kicked off
at 4:00 p.m.
You can tell it was really
important for Biden,
because that's right in
the middle of dinner.
[ Laughter ]
"4:00 is when
I put my jammies on."
Yeah, it was his first
formal press conference
at the White House
since March of last year.
In Biden's defense, that one
just wrapped up a few days ago.
[ Laughter ]
"I had an old friend named
Three-Toed Larry."
[ Laughter ]
"He had a big toe, a middle toe,
and another big toe."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech, Biden said
that we're in a better place
with COVID
than we've been before.
Then a reporter sneezed,
and everyone hit the floor.
[ Laughter ]
Biden also said, "Should we have
done more testing earlier?
Yes, but we're doing more now."
And he spent the next hour
asking himself questions until
the press conference was over.
[ Laughter ]
"Is the economy rebounding?
Yeah.
Did I see the new 'Spider-Man'?
No.
Do I like superhero movies?
Yeah."
But here's some good news.
Madame Tussauds just unveiled
their new figure
of President Biden.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience oohs ]
Weirdly enough, that wax statue
has a 60% approval rating.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Some more news, I saw that
the January 6th committee
just issued subpoenas
to a few more of Trump's
former associates, including
his old lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
You could tell Rudy
is not a very good lawyer,
because the first thing
he did he was google,
"What is a subpoena?"
[ Laughter ]
Rudy said he'd only comply
if his lawyer was present.
Then he put a sock over his hand
and said,
"I'm Mr. Giuliani's counsel."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, if you google
Giuliani's subpoena,
they show you a clip
from the "Borat" movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Some TV news.
PBS just announced
that "Arthur,"
the longest-running animated
kids show in history,
will end next month
with a four --
[ Audience "aws" ]
...with a four-part finale
that shows the characters
as grown-ups.
Yeah, aardvarks only live about
20 years,
so this could get kind of heavy.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Arthur as a kid.
Yeah.
And here he is as grown-up.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's interesting.
So this is going to be cute.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, listen to this.
The CEO of Airbnb said that
he's going to permanently live
in Airbnb properties
and move to a new one
every two weeks.
Yeah. The CEO of Motel 6 heard
this idea and was like,
"Do not expect that from me."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I read that Peloton
is reportedly considering
scaling back
and closing some stores.
We're three weeks into January.
I didn't expect my bike
to be the one giving up.
Today marks one full year
in office for President Biden.
It's been a challenging year.
When asked what he's learned,
Biden said,
"Being vice president
was a hell of a lot more fun."
[ Laughter ]
A year ago, Biden pledged
to address COVID, the economy,
climate change,
and racial injustice.
And good news -- after 12 months
of tireless effort,
we're all getting
three free masks.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
This is nice.
Biden's inaugural committee
marked his anniversary
by releasing a video
touting America's recovery,
narrated by Tom Hanks.
Hanks wasn't the first choice,
but staffers had to explain
to Biden that Gary Cooper
died 60 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, yesterday, in his
two-hour press conference,
Biden --
two-hour press conference?
[ Laughter ]
Biden covered a lot
and said the U.S.
might not do anything
if Russia's invasion of Ukraine
is only minor.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
One of his few slip-ups.
And it's a big deal,
'cause at Biden's age, any slip
could be a catastrophe.
You know...
[ Laughter ]
What is a minor invasion?
A soldier sticks one foot
in Ukraine?
He's like, "Just kidding!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, today, Biden tried
to clear things up by saying
any Russian invasion
would be met
with severe economic response.
Biden was like,
"Try me, tough guy,
and I'll turn your economy
into ours."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, over time, Biden will hit
Putin with economic penalties.
In other words, Biden is using
the same strategy as Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
"It's only another dollar.
Can't stop now."
[ Laughter ]
During the press conference,
Biden also said
that Kamala Harris would be his
running mate again in 2024.
Then he mentioned
they're already working
on potential campaign slogans
for their re-election.
Take a look at these.
First up, there's...
[ Laughter ]
Next, they have...
And, finally, there's...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Pretty good.
Some business news --
today Amazon announced
that this year,
it's opening its own
clothing store,
called Amazon Style.
Though I'm not sure
Amazon Style is the best option
when your founder
dresses like this.
But I don't know. Maybe I'm...
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Amazon is focusing on clothing.
Even crazier,
Abercrombie & Fitch
is going to start
launching people into space.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that...
Well, this is fun.
I saw that Queen Elizabeth
is getting into
the condiment business.
That's right.
She's releasing her own
Royal Estate tomato sauce.
Yeah, the Queen says
tomato sauce is just like
her mother's servant
used to make.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Last week, Prince Andrew
was stripped
of his royal status,
and now his official Twitter
and YouTube accounts
have been deleted.
The Queen was like,
"No Twitter, no YouTube.
Now go to your castle."
[ Laughter ]
I saw that the CEO of crypto.com
just confirmed that it suffered
a security breach, and hundreds
of accounts were hacked.
That's terrible.
I mean, if you can't trust
a website called crypto.com...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard that police
in Canada are looking for a man
who allegedly stole
an $8,000 guitar
by hiding it in his pants.
[ Laughter ]
The first giveaway?
Guitar-shaped pants.
[ Laughter ]
When he was approached
by security, he was like,
"Oh, I walked in with
this guitar in my pants."
[ Laughter ]
The guy was easy to spot.
He was the one
walking away
from the store like...
[ Guitar strumming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Strumming continues ]
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a home listing
in Wisconsin has gone viral
because of the house's
unusual bathroom setup.
Take a look at this. It's real.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-It's weird when you knock
on the door, and three people
are like, "Occupied!"
[ Laughter ]
♪ Occupied ♪
-♪ Occupied ♪
-Today the White House launched
a new phone line
that Americans can call
to order their free COVID tests.
Yeah, which means
100 million Americans
spent the day screaming,
"Representative!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Representative!
Human!"
Yep, the phone line is open
from 8:00 a.m. to midnight.
Somehow, the QVC phone lines
are open 24 hours a day,
but the COVID hotline isn't.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, we're a couple weeks
from the Winter Olympics
and, due to COVID concerns,
China is limiting
the torch relay
to just three days.
[ Laughter ]
And this is smart --
to maintain social distancing,
the runners will just throw
the torch to each other.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, thanks to COVID,
the Olympics
are going to look
a little different.
I saw that NBC decided
not to send
its announcers to Beijing,
and, instead, they'll call
the games from Connecticut.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
That's right. Connecticut,
instead of the Olympics.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But on the bright side,
there'll be the same amount
of people wearing Ralph Lauren
in both places.
-[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-Announcers are upset
because there's nothing like
being there in person
to experience these
electrifying moments.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Well, this made me laugh --
Last night,
Trump called in to "Hannity,"
and at one point,
Hannity used a phrase
with the word "wall" in it,
which immediately sent Trump
into his own world.
Listen to this.
-So, you know,
you keep banging your head
against the wall,
why would you expect
a different result?
-So, we would've had the wall
completed in three weeks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was largely completed.
-No.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, no, not -- Trump's
like a Golden Retriever.
A few key words
make him go wild.
Like, "Wall, wall?
[ Panting ]
Who said wall?
Who said wall?"
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
the upcoming "Batman" movie
staring Robert Pattinson
will be one of the longest
superhero movies ever,
with a run time
of almost three hours.
[ Audience ohs ]
Americans were like,
"I'm not going to sit
through a three-hour movie..."
and then settled in
for 14 hours of football.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
That's right, three hours,
and there are plans
to extend the film
into a fourth hour,
hosted by Hoda & Jenna.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's great.
That's a good idea.
In hindsight,
they probably didn't need
20 minutes of Alfred
ironing the Batsuit.
[ Laughter ]
[As Michael Caine] "Your cape's
almost ready, Mr. Wayne."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Speaking of movies....
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of movies,
the State of New York --
Did you see this?
They just announced
that movie theaters
can now sell alcohol.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, no, no, no.
No, no, I don't think
that's a good idea at all.
[ Laughter ]
No. You know the annoying guy
who yells stuff at the screen?
Imagine him after eight beers,
you know?
Seriously,
by the end of "Batman,"
it's going to be like
"Royal Rumble."
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
Well, it's been a tough week
for Netflix.
After admitting that all
the streaming competition
has slowed growth,
their stock plummeted
and they had their worst day
in years.
Yeah, at the board meeting,
someone was like,
"I don't know. Maybe 94 shows
about cakes is too much?"
[ Laughter ]
But don't worry.
Netflix isn't going anywhere.
Mostly because
"Disney+ and chill"
doesn't quite have
the same ring to it.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, an underwear brand
called Parade
has a new recycling program
that turns their customers'
old underwear
into furniture and bedding.
[ Audience groans ]
Even Greta Thunberg was like,
"Hell no!"